[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici éleveur de buf pays depuis bientôt
25 ans Rito Waro s'est lancé plus
récemment en diversification dans
l'élevage de moutons son chtel est
toujourd'hui constitué de brobis de race
charolaise réputé pour leur qualité
bouchère et qu'il nourrit principalement
avec le fourrage de
l'exploitation moi je fais la la
plantation de foin et c'est récolté chez
moi
donc au lie lie c'est eux qui vont aller
à chercher c'est moi qui ramène pour eux
là c'est de la qualité là on il apprécie
ouais ils apprécient bien et Machin et
puis vous voyez même les animaux c'est
pas c'est c'est c'est c'est des belles
bêtes vraiment son troupeau compte
aujourd'hui 120 brebis m des bêtes
magnifiques qui peuvent produire chaque
année jusqu'à 280 agneaux ce côté on a
gardé c'est plutôt les Agnels de de
renouvellement qu'on peut renouver dans
le troupeau donc on a gardé quelquesunes
et de ce côté bah voilà c'est c'est
l'agneau que qui serait prêt pour pas
quoi donc il font environ de 45 45 kg
sur pied pour a un agneau entre 18 et 20
kg carcasse ils ont bien profité pour
pour 6 mois ils ont bien développé donc
c'est c'est vraiment l'agneau pay qui
mange de l'herbe ils ont de l'herbe à
volonté et voilà du foin à volonté et
des conditions deélevage optimal
permettent ainsi à Rito de produire des
animaux de qualité de l'agneau 100 %
pays qui est de plus en plus apprécié
par les consommateurs
réunionnés la Réunion ch la Réunion
copie un petit peu à comme comme comme
les gens qui qui fait à l'extérieur moi
j'ai remarqué ben avant on connaissait
pas par exemple Hoï maintenant la
Réunion fait Hoï maintenant ça arrive la
période par avant peut-être les
Réunionnais ne mangeent pas de d'agneau
po maintenant bon le repas logiquement
pour c'est l'agneau donc on a créé un
petit atelier et puis voilà aue
maintenant les gens achètent l'agneau
importé ben il faut penser qu'il y a
l'agneau pays l'agneau pays de qualité
qui qui commence à la
Réunion lui aussi commence toujours dans
cette nouvelle filière depuis 6 mois
seulement Olivier bar a rejoint la jeune
coopérative hovap celle-ci compte
aujourd'hui une quarantaine d'éleveurs
adhérents 30 en mouton et 10 en cabri
pour abriter son cheptel Olivier a
choisi une structure peu habituelle ici
à la Réunion légère rapide et facile à
installer je crois que c'est l'un des
premiers qu'on a vu dans la coopérative
à faire ça
[Applaudissements]
et T déjà pour voir comment ça va réagir
dessous les moutons et c'est une bâche
une bâche épaisse
dessus pour pour empêcher un peu la
chaleur d' rentré jeune agriculteur
Olivier suit les traces de son père et
s'occupe désormais à pleintemps de la
partie animale de
l'exploitation les animaux lui c'est son
dada il est depuis tout petit il est
dedans donc avec la possibilité de faire
du
mouton ça a été une une bonne
opportunité pour lui et il s'est
intéressé depuis le début quoi B on
cherchait un truc pour diversifier un
peu l'exploitation et
comme ici on est un peu limité en place
et et en structure donc le mouton était
une bonne un bon compromis
[Musique]
quoi
adhérant de la coopérative hovicap su
paayette est l'un des 10 éleveurs
caprins de la jeune structure su a
choisi quant à lui d'élever des Croisés
beè une race de chèvre réputé pour ses
qualités bouchères voilà c'est pour
faire de la viande et pour avoir un bon
rendement de carcasse aussi voilà et
pour la productivité a peut-être sera
j'père sera un bon résultat voilà pour
la production de jeun cabri et
renouvellement
Dutel peut effectivement compter sur les
performances de ces deux magnifiques
boues de race pure c'est issu de
laassation
artificielle c'est un fils de
Vitus
bon là il y a 2 ans 2 ans juillet voilà
et donc pour moi c'est un joli beau
ramener du sang nouveau avec un bonb bon
environ 10 chèvres donc normalement les
tous les chèvres peut-être une une ou
deux sera pas pleine mais en général
tout toutes les pleines voilà juste à
côté d'autres chèvres attendent
tranquillement la confirmation de leur
gestation voilà c'est des chèvres et des
chevrettes et chèvres déjà mis avec le B
avec magitu et là l' enlever dedans
quand un joueur va faire l'échographie
pour voir le résultat donc ce sont qui
sont ici là voilà donc là es attendent
patiemment voir si si es sont gestantes
quoi voilà comme on dit faut pas les
bousquer voilà il faut pas trop les
bousculer parce que sinon pe perde voilà
après la mise bas il faudra encore une
dizaine de mois d'élevage pour obtenir
un jeune cabri bien conformé et prêt à
la
commercialisation ici c'est un l'OT B à
l'engrcement moyenne 9 mois et il doit
sortir ce moisci le mois d'avril vendu
àov qui distribu dans les points de
vente boucherie voilà lentement mais
sûrement la coopérative des petit
ruminant se développe afin de proposer
aux consommateurs runonnais du cabri
pays frais tout au long de l'année pour
l'instant on peut pas fournir
régulièrement des des des des cabriis
mais on y travaille pour arriver et on
fait pour l'instant on sorte les CIS
exceptionnellement pour des périodes de
parc fête des mer fites des pè Noël ou
des trucs comme ça prie festive plutôt
que que régulier mais après l'objectif
de de V c'est d'arriver à avoir une
production régulière pour pour les
consommateurs c'est sûr qu'il y a encore
du travail à faire mais on avance à
petit pas et on va
[Musique]
réussir